first of all congratulations on the
partnership with neutrogena this is
incredible
thank you uh what made i guess uh hallie
i'll start with you what made you guys
the perfect fit for neutrogena
oh wow well we have always been huge
fans of neutrogena ever since we were
younger
and we truly feel like our
values and what we stand for really adds
up with the brand
just about being unapologetically
yourself and not being afraid to bear
who you really
are and show the world so my sister and
i were so happy to
partnership with them and um you know
just
be a part of a brand that is inclusive
to all skin types
which was something that was really
important to us and we feel really
grateful to be a part of it
and uh chloe i want to get your thoughts
on this um when it does come to sort of
confidence in your own skin
and loving yourself with that
now often comes backlash for some
incredibly
i don't know insane reason and you
recently went through that and then what
you got in return
was just unbelievable support from
friends and strangers and i just want to
know how that felt
to get the support back after going
through something as awful as that
it felt truly truly amazing and i think
it's so much bigger than me because
women
of all skin types of all kinds and
everything go through that
where they are ridiculed for simply
being and
i'm just grateful that i have my best
friend my sister
to be there to help support me as well
as the love and support from everyone
around the world
it just meant so much to me and when i
see posts from women
who are posting themselves whether it's
their face or their body and saying that
they feel confident to do that because
i do it it just means so much and i just
hope my sister and i can continue to
inspire
women and even men to love themselves
and it's a journey
that's really never ending and some days
i feel more confident some days i feel
pretty insecure but
it's just about finding that balance and
just learning to love yourself through
it all
and i'm happy that uh neutrogena kind of
really helps us
fall in love with our natural beauty
because it's all about getting the skin
and the face and the glow right so it
works hand in hand and i think that's
why i'm really really excited
uh people love seeing you guys together
and i'm sure you
love being to together but hallie you
you weren't there when chloe was going
through that what was
what was that like for you to not
physically be in the same space
uh as chloe when she was going through
all that yeah
so it was hard so i'm the little sister
so
if anybody you know says or does
anything to my older sister i'm like you
know i'm ready
i'm there right so basically
um you know we were just having lots of
face time conversations
and i get really defensive and
protective of my sister because she
is definitely my world and anybody who
has anything negative to say
is obviously just jealous and i'm so
proud of my sister for owning
who she is and being proud of that um
because that's what we're meant to do i
mean
women we don't have to just be one thing
we don't just have to be
just one thing we can be everything we
can be sexy and smart and confident and
professional all at the same time
there's so many different layers to us
and i'm so very proud of my sister for
standing up for herself
i love you and and listening to the two
of you talk it is
it is very apparent um why
you're the perfect person for to bring
little mermaid back into a new world
uh what is that experience been like i
know i know you can't talk about it a
lot but
but what can you say how has that
experience been because this is uh this
is a big this is a big change and it's a
change that
most people since the day that they
first saw that movie and they loved that
movie but they realized that it needs to
move forward and you are the person to
do that what's that pressure like for
you
oh my goodness you know it is definitely
a blessing
the ability to be able to be here i'm in
london right now to be filming right now
um and this movie has touched so many
people
especially me ever since i was younger i
think this was my favorite disney movie
when i was younger so it is very surreal
and um you know there is kind of this
overwhelming feeling of wow i have so
much to live up to sometimes
but just recognizing this blessing and
realizing that i was
put in this position for a reason and
i'm just going to give it my all and do
my best and
make ariel mine in that way and that's
all i can do
so have you had a day on set with jacob
tremblay yet
i have yes
yes we love it he's the best
yeah he is yes that's why that's why i
asked i mean melissa mccarthy is
incredible but jacob trombley is just
you know he's jacob
uh congratulations on the on the grammys
you guys were so
incredible with what you did during
lockdown
the the inventive sort of ways you guys
brought ungodly hour
uh to to fans and what does it mean to
be recognized i know there's a lot of
different opinions right now going into
especially this year's grammys
but what does this mean to you guys it
means absolutely everything
to us i'm just grateful that a ceremony
is still happening
amidst a pandemic and i
i miss my sister to pieces and even
though we will be on opposite sides of
the world
i'm so proud of us whether we win or not
it is the best feeling to be recognized
by your peers for the music that you
put all your blood sweat and tears into
and
in the same house that i'm sitting in
right now sis and i will be up into the
wee hours of the morning working so hard
and to see uh the love and the joy that
we were able to bring
out of it during a pandemic and put some
smiles on people's faces and just
distract them from the craziness
sometimes
that's really all we could ask for and i
think the music did its job so
we'll see what happens with the grammys
i'm hoping and i'm praying
so we'll see is it is it overwhelming at
times to have such a big fan in beyonce
not overwhelming it's a wonderful
feeling
yes it's like the best feeling it's not
overwhelming
it's like you know when you like jump on
a really big bean bag and you just feel
engulfed in love and cushion and support
that's what it feels like
[Laughter]
did she reach out to you after after her
dad after matthew
was asked about you and the comparisons
in that interview did beyonce reach out
and just try and cool things down a
little bit i love beyonce because she
always shows us support and love
and you know none of that affected me
because she's queen bee she
no one can compare no one can touch her
i just love her so much and it's all
love and positivity from here
and uh and sp and and you have to have i
mean at this point being the ages that
you are when did you realize that
you know your skin was as thick as it
was and that you guys could handle
anything that was going to come your way
in this business
oh my goodness well i think we're still
figuring it out
but i think from a young age we had to
realize that we had to have tough skin
i mean we were posting ourselves on
youtube
from the ten and eight years old and i
remember we would
like the first 100 views or first a
thousand views and we would get like 10
comments and
we'd be like oh my gosh wow what are
people saying and sometimes seeing that
one comment of somebody just being
ignorant
and rude would hurt our feelings right
so over time we have learned like
everybody's gonna have an opinion
and that's okay but just remembering
that what you have within
is beautiful and what you're doing if
it's making you happy then that's all
that matters
um so yeah and we're still we remind
each other that all the time because
we're human at times
people's words do hurt but you have to
keep your head up
and you have to keep going so we're each
other's constant reminder of that
you